[Music]
ellen
is in new jersey hi ellen welcome to the
ramsey show
hi how are you today better than i
deserve what's up
um i was just curious me and my husband
were trying to figure out what to do
about our money because
he's working at a sales job and he's not
meeting as much as we were hoping to be
your phone your phone sucks can you
speak directly into it we're having
trouble understanding you
uh sure um hang on let me see it's
really
nice too loud hold on
okay is that better yes ma'am thank you
i'm sorry start again so
maybe we can understand you now um
my husband is a sales uh insurance
salesman
and we're projected to make a certain
amount of money but because of uh
issues with his job and things we're not
making enough
um and he has a bad history of like work
history
so we've been trying to repair it by
keeping it jobs for certain lengths of
time
but we're not really making enough money
to make ends meet so i'm not sure what
we should do
so he's on straight commission and y'all
are starving to death
well he has a little bit uh he's like
two thousand dollars
a month of uh almost two thousand
dollars a month of um
base pay so we can get at least
yes but he's obviously not a good
insurance salesman
no unfortunately okay so he does need
another job i don't care what his work
history is yeah when you say he has a
bad
work history you're trying to repair
what does that mean means he's not
staying on the job very long
yeah he had a history of not staying
with jobs very long the last few years
we've
been working on fixing that why um
when he was working with his family his
family needed a lot of help
he's kind of off the work a lot and he'd
get fired for those reasons
but um yeah he'd get fired because his
family needed a lot of help you mean
because he didn't go to work
with his family yeah
okay when did that stop
that stopped um actually after he
started beating me
i started pushing him to work harder and
he did start working a lot harder
how long ago losing a whole lot since
then um that's
about 2 000 and i'd say it's about 2018
it really started improving okay so he's
held a job since 2018 fairly steadily
yeah he's helped different jobs but he's
not like been fired from any of them and
he's been studying
being working all the time so that he
has been doing
oh here's the deal he's got to go get
another job he's got to get two or three
of them
and he's not going to make a lot of
money at the hourly wage but he needs to
start making some money
that's where you're at and i know you'll
have a dream right now of hey we're
going to make this
this is going to be the job that bails
him out of all the other bad jobs
that's not where you're at right now
y'all got to eat you're an emergency
so he's got to go to lowe's and he's got
to go drive uber at night and he's got
to get up and
i don't think they have paper routes
anymore he's got to find a morning job
too and he's going to be working three
days
three jobs six days a week seven days a
week and he's just got to get cracking
so um alan you sound like you're taking
care of a little boy to me that's
exactly right
like he doesn't want to work much like
he's lazy and you're covering for him in
this call
that was the case originally and it's
not anymore i'm actually a state home
mom so he's been doing most of the
actual working
i know but he's not he's not working
it's not it's not working
yeah that makes sense yeah like the
reason he sucks as an insurance salesman
is because he doesn't do it
he's not making sales
yeah yeah okay so what what you need to
do
are you guys in a good church
actually just joined a better church
wonderful your
church was too far away but now we're
the good ones wonderful okay i want you
to i want him to plug in with some guys
that are a little bit older than him and
start to develop some relationships with
some guys who
have a high quality work ethic
and who have big goals for their lives
and let him start hanging around with
those guys
because i think no one has ever taught
him how to do those things right he's
got some family challenges i get that
um well i think his family that didn't
allow him to work much
so he had to stop and help them they
don't work much that's what i'm saying
right now any picture of what that even
looks like it's like you know yeah
but i also know guys like this that it's
always a scheme it's the next thing
yeah and well you look for when you're
desperate you look for stupid ideas
there you go
and you just need to work real hard for
a long time yeah and don't
don't don't jump on the pipe dreams just
go get something where you can hustle
and grind and grind out some money
and just be steady and be the tortoise
and somebody will be there
ahead of you and you'll get hey i need
you to take this shift we're going to
make you assistant maybe that's how
that'll work
just just if you just show up work and
work while you're at work and smile
while you're at work and work while
you're at work and smile while you're at
work and you show up all the time and
you do that
all of a sudden magic stuff starts
happening it just does i mean it's just
incredible what ends up happening
because
here's the thing most people don't show
up and work at work
or they show up to work and they're
jerks to be around yeah that's the magic
yeah do your job and don't be an idiot
ta-dah make a million dollars that's
like the slogan
i'm gonna write that book do your job
and don't be an idiot how about that
but i mean that's that's all of it it's
like you know if you just
show up and care fun to be around and
care
all day long and smile while you're
there dad come man
you're just like you're just like in the
top percent right there
before you did anything else you don't
even have to be that good at how did the
bar
for life get so low
just show up to the job that you just
show up it's not just him
we're not talking about your house we're
talking about everybody now yes okay so
just just
yeah be at work while you're at work
work
real hard it's a formula
and don't be dizzy get off of facebook
you're supposed to be working
you're supposed to be working don't be
watching youtube catch
videos everything's gonna be working to
every guy work while you're at work who
has had a past where they've struggled
and now you're in it and you've got a
incredible woman like this by your side
and this is gonna be the job and you get
in and you're trying to sell you're
trying to sell
and it's not working be honest
be open about it and transition to
something else don't think you're saving
anybody by drowning your whole family
and that's how people end up you know
two years later and sixty thousand
dollars in secret credit card debt
nonsense like that